as blac chyna's civil suit against her
ex rob kardashian's family continues a
source tells et the 35 year old reality
star is focused on their five-year-old
daughter dreams
your tomato
tomato
tomato
no tomato
e.t source explains that throughout the
trial of which rob is not a defendant
he's been at home taking care of dream
adding that he has her six days a week
quote he has been trying to keep things
as routine and normal as possible for
her while all this is going on the
source adds that rob wants to be present
and make sure his little girl feels
secure and safe despite the family drama
of course this all comes amid a tense
courtroom battle between the 33 year old
model and the kardashians
china first filed the 100 million dollar
civil suit in october 2017 against rob
for assault battery and harassment and
his family for defamation claiming that
the kardashian jenners became quote
media predators slut-shaming her on
social media
and killing her hit television show as a
form of revenge for leaving rob
why do you care you shouldn't do my
phone there's nothing i mean don't you
think that's shady my mom or something
about me i don't want you to be i'm
gonna go read your convos with your mom
so what are you trying to read who do
you think i'm texting what do you think
i'm doing on thursday rob's mom kris
jenner took the stand and was questioned
about statements she'd made during
previous depositions about alleged
threats she'd been told chyna made
against her daughter kylie jenner of
course kylie used to date rapper tyga
who is the father of china's
nine-year-old son king cairo
but chris told the court they never
reported the alleged threats to the
police quote we kept it internal between
the family and when the 66 year old
momager was asked if those alleged
threats caused her any concern when rob
and chyna started dating she said she
didn't realize how serious the
relationship was until they got engaged
she says she put her worries aside
because she wanted them to have a happy
ending
quote they were working on past mistakes
and we hoped for the best and for them
to change but it didn't
it might get crazy at times so i'm not
sure how he's going to react and while
rob's famous family has showed up in
court to support him e.t source says he
has no issue appearing if he is called
as a witness but until then quote
spending time with dream is his main
priority
can you put the horses back
please can you put that
can you put that
since rob and chyna split in 2017 he's
kept a low profile but in 2019 kim
gushed over her little bro during a chat
with e.t
he definitely is more low-key than all
of us and we love that and respect that
and we love having him around he's doing
really good and earlier that year chloe
gave e.t this update
rob's doing great he really is and you
know he's been working out and he's
kicking ass and i just want rob to do
what's best for him and what makes him
happy and if that makes him happy then
we will all support him
[Music]
you